I want to
turn to
something on the Democratic side
that emerged this weekend.
There is growing
angst that
potential potential
third party challengers
Robert Kennedy Jr.
And Marianne
Williamson could really hurt
president biden's reelection chances.
RFK Jr.
The New York Post reports
with video it's not just their account
spreading some really deranged lies
about the CO, about COVID,
that they really walk into anti-Semitism
and anti-Asian bigotry.
The New York Post has a tape of Kennedy
saying, quote, COVID 19.
There's an argument that it is
ethnically targeted.
COVID 19
is targeted to attack Caucasians
and black people.
The people who are most immune
are Ashkenazi Jews and Chinese.
We don't know
know whether it's deliberately targeted
that or not.
We do know that the Chinese
are spending hundreds
of millions of dollars
developing ethno
ethnic bioweapon INS, unquote.
There is no truth to this.
There are
plenty of Ashkenazi Jews
and plenty of Chinese and Asian people
died of COVID.
It's a deranged argument.
But this guy is posing.
He's polling in the double digits
among Democrats.
Well, but again,
I think that is about more about
name recognition.
His own family doesn't support him.
And as you just said,
that is a deranged,
disgusting thing to say.
Let's just be very clear.
It does not represent the values
of the Democratic Party.
So I think when voters he's
not on the ballot
in any states,
and I think when voters actually
get to hear him say things like that,
those numbers will fall.
I'm not concerned.
And as the congresswoman said,
the fundraising numbers from the Biden
campaign are just shot up.
The people who have been you know,
wringing their hands,
we see it every cycle.
I'm very confident
in President Biden's ability
to run a solid campaign.
And the last thing I'll say
very quickly is in part because,
you know,
a lot of what 20, 24 is going to be about
is who is an idiot
who gets to be an American.
When we talk about the defense
authorization bill,
I mean, a lot of what is in
there are anti LGBTQ, anti-woman, anti
civil rights.
And we're seeing this at the state level.
We're seeing this at the federal level.
And it's calling it culture wars.
That's a disservice.
Yeah.
So I want to say on Karen's point, too,
about the people
who have been kind of underestimating
President Biden,
I think that his fundraising
numbers need to be a wake up
call to Republicans as well,
because I feel like a lot of
people are pointing to his low
approval ratings and everything
but if Republicans nominate
someone like Donald Trump,
then Biden could
succeed and win reelection.
But I think if we put up anyone else,
we could pose a threat to Biden.
But these fundraising numbers
are really strong.
Any thoughts on
what Robert Kennedy had to say?
I mean, I can't
I have to echo the fact
that it's nauseating and disgusting
and divisive
and the Democratic Party
has no room for that sort of narrative.
I don't think he will gain any traction.
And I'm not worried about it.
I am confident that it will end up
being a rematch of Biden and Trump.
And I believe President
Biden will prevail